what made you want to become a
production designer over everything else
passion I was I've always loved history
I've always loved drawing you know so
the combination of those two things and
as a child I think I was honestly I was
about eight years old and I thought I
want to do that job and it was you know
at the time when they were all those BBC
costume dramas that was completely
obsessed with and I used to make period
clothes for my Barbie dolls and I mean
it's kind of inevitable that I've ended
up doing what I do it I've been a
monomaniac about it actually I wasn't
sidetracked I sort of knew that's what I
want to do and Here I am doing it and
still enjoying it
tink Taylor so excite will you give an
initial briefing of your look at the bar
set and we give my various images to
maybe look at that you could follow I
will start conceiving of how I see a
film from the first time I read a script
which is obviously before I'm even
interviewed for the job and I tend to
fight if I don't have a very strong idea
straight away what I think it should
look like it's not the right film to be
doing cool that makes an initial
attraction to the script yeah and and
this really appealed to me I'm in this
material I desperately want I think it's
fair to say I've never wanted to get the
job as Marilla this one I love Let The
Right One In I came out of the cinema
completely blown away by on every level
and I just remember saying this guy I
really really really want to work with
and you know luckily for me pick me up
which is great which was fantastic the
color palette for Tim Taylor is so
strong and deliver what was the thinking
behind I think it comes like it comes
very naturally from from the subject
matter I think it's what it's almost
wrong if it's contrived in this case if
you if you gather the visual references
together you put them on the wall the
color palette is there so I'm people
knows if the kind of spaces you're
looking at the kind of things you're
looking at yeah it and your and your
editing as you're putting together as
you're pulling together references
you're naturally editing stuff that feel
right or doesn't feel right and you know
and often the colors that you're using
is to do with that it's all about the
world you're creating I mean you know
would have been completely ridiculous if
Tinker Tailor was you know I don't know
blue or red or whatever it is this dusty
smoky 70s world where you're the muted
color I'm you know
oh but we had some really punchy strong
colors in there as well yes oh no no we
had we weren't afraid of color so there
was sort of overall palette of sludge
and then every now and again a good old
punch you know whether that was a bus
going by and suddenly a flash of red or
if it was you know Connie had a
particularly bright orange bedspread
yeah so we were we were not afraid of
using color in its really sure
Oh interested in your present bits
pieces maybe some how you start out and
like the development process you take
well very I mean you start at the very
early stages first thing you do is the
director and I along with the location
team start looking at locations your
works very place with locations yeah
yeah well will will have between us will
have a you know a brief and then they
will show photographs and from there you
go and start looking at the places and
between us we cook up this this world
and then I would go away and start doing
sketches and I sill in a very
old-fashioned way and draw with pencil
ooh there's this this was for actually
for a CGI shot that appears in the film
that the exterior of mi6 is the building
that exists and we stretched it and
plant this brutalist block in the middle
the building around the edge is
somewhere that is right across the road
from where I did my Saturday yoga class
when I did my interview I already knew
where mi6 was I knew that was mi6 Thomas
loved it and that became my six he had
this very strong idea before I started
that this this Secret Service this mi6
world mm-hmm
was like it like a building within
another building so the central building
it was hidden within the outer core and
he had this notion of this brutalist
lump stuck in something that to the
outside world looks like a bureaucratic
accordion building this was where pre
dough is imprisoned it was this tiny
little block and I did this sketch would
be sort of Auschwitz like posts and
Thomas laughed I remember him chortling
when I showed him this drawing he'd said
ah yes
that the hut was a location and then we
build around it
so these places do you go out and
purposely find it are they from maybe if
you've been somewhere before you think
ah that could work for this you always
really oh it's a mixture you can just
know if you know I had been to Budapest
once in my life you know so you know
you're relying on you to show you places
and I think it's important when you're
doing a film like this where you don't
have huge amounts of resources that you
stay open and you let in select
locations inspire you did you draw on
any personal experiences oh god yeah
everything and anything we did draw on
our memory I mean you know we all Thomas
came to to London for the first time I
think in the mid 70s and we had our
memories of what that London was like
and we talked about it and laughed about
it and I had terrible the food was and
you know the wimpy bar being something
that as kids we really relish it was a
big treat to get to get a Wimpy and so
we had to get that into the film but
it's so many different things that that
you know pulled together the visuals for
and it's really interesting because I do
do so much visual research and I put
these images all up on the wall it's
like wallpaper from floor to ceiling and
once you've done that the color palette
just jumps out at you it's quite
extraordinary because you're as you're
making those choices of what images are
interesting and which ones aren't you're
editing it anyway
and when you put everything in the wall
you really see it and it's it really
gives you a sense for the film and it's
very nice way of communicating that to
everyone else in the production who are
maybe not so visual so you know people
from different departments can come in
and oh okay this is what it's going to
look like
also my background my father's half
Montana green and half Russian and my
mother is checked so as a Kate wheezed
gone holidays behind the Iron Curtain
and I had really really vivid memories
of what that you know a world that's
gone it just doesn't exist and that's
one of the things that appealed to me
hugely when I read the script and
actually in lilyc re it's set in
Czechoslovakia for budgetary reasons I
think it just turned out to be slightly
cheaper to be shooting in Budapest
became hungry and when I went to my
interview I had a massive stuff of
photographs of Czechoslovakia at the
time and Thomas didn't have the heart to
tell me that it had already moved to put
up especially with period films and how
closely do you work with set dressing
and props Oh incredibly closely is that
absolutely the closest relationship
tatiana who is we I think the film would
think it was our 12th film together so
you can imagine you know by then it's
telepathy almost you know we we have
very compatible tastes and very that's
why we've done so many films together
you know it just really works and that
relationship is vital and I'm very
involved in that whole thing because to
me the set dressing is such an important
part of any film and and you know TAC
and I have a kind of weird we have very
very odd well not ugly
considering what we do very very similar
to so much so that will turn up to work
both dressed I did in fact I to phone we
had to phone each other what are you
wearing to be buses in case you didn't
come kind of you know just exactly the
same
was that one moment for you that you
thought was sort of the proudest or the
best really shattered that he has been
touching that moment but on this phone
there were so many things that I kind of
thought yes this is good this works the
Istanbul hotel where Thomas wanted to
see from literally from one window
across the road into a building with
each of these spaces being contiguous so
you can actually see her move from one
room to the next to the next to the next
you know and he was the one who spotted
this fantastic brutalist building in
Aldrich so we did this mad thing which
was shoot the Istanbul hotel room I
built all those rooms behind that
elevation and then Ricki Tarr is across
the road actually in Istanbul and then
we put Istanbul in post off to once I
got rid of the London buses and put in
some Turkish traffic it was it was all
it was this was a really in I can
honestly say this was one of the most
kind of stimulating creative food
productions I've ever worked on how many
sets and locations are there seems to me
quite set numbers on Tinker Tailor I can
tell you exactly 110 well yeah that's
110 different spaces there's a lot yeah
how long is that how long did you oh god
I can't remember now we probably had
about 12 weeks perfect and in that and
the Budapest bit of the shoot was in our
pre pre production period so take
another week out of that and the prep
time in Budapest about 10 weeks lots of
spaces and that's the amazing thing that
you create all these worlds in that
incredibly short period of time so you
know it goes from typed out words on a
white page and 10 weeks later they're
all these worlds that you've created so
it's kind of kind of crazy accelerated
manic but fun do you normally find that
your first initial ideas are maybe the
best and we always go back it's really
interesting how I tend to keep all my
visual references and you look back on
them and it's interesting house how
similar the final outcome yeah quite
often it's off you don't diverge or go
off on I mean
so by doing that by providing so much
visual information at an interview stage
slightly putting my head on the block
because the directors going to like it
or not like it of course it and it means
I'll get the job or not get the job but
in a way I think it's better because
then at least you know yeah the film
I've just started is Ray finds his in
physical woman and I went to the
interview I had so many books I had to
come with a suitcase silly but I got the
job anyway so but it is to try and get
as much yeah so it's yes it's communica
sexually if you're talking about
aesthetics and you're talking about the
look of a film it's much easier to
actually have an example you know it's
all talking aesthetics can just be hot
air it's much easier to say look these
are the colors this is what I'm
imagining this shows you the atmosphere
is there any particular genre film that
you haven't maybe covered when you were
designing that you'd maybe like to take
maybe reinvent oh I've never I mean I've
um I do like doing period film you do
that period yeah I do I love it I love
the idea of recreating a world that no
longer exists I've never done anything
set in the future how did you feel about
it I don't know I don't know it depends
entirely on the script I'm always script
driven that it has to be so sweet if you
like the script it's strong yeah and you
might get a period film that you know
you read a script for and you come away
kind of going god I don't know what
that's supposed to look like
yeah or you read something and it just
engages you know engages one's
imagination
what advice could you give to us what is
dying now and going into our core and in
general what advice I think I think you
need to be really passionate about it I
think that is so important and I think
and I think grasp every opportunity
that's the other thing because I think
you know you will go through you what
you're doing at the film school is
really exciting and you know you're
doing all this creative stuff and
suddenly you've got a job in an art
department where you will be making tea
for people and that's very bloody boring
but but the thing is that if just take
every opportunity don't don't be sniffy
about anything just do it get your hands
dirty because I know and I'm really I
really mean this when I employ somebody
in the art department I know at the end
of the first week who's going to carry
on and who is it so I think that's
that's the main thing